we talked about container builder before
but we only really scratched the surface
of what it can do in this episode of the
cloud rolling update it's time to play
with multi-step bills and container
builder special thanks again I'm Matt
and Kelsey for teaching me about this
make sure to check out their content
linked in the description below a single
docker file doesn't always get you what
you need and in fact it's common to use
multiple steps in the build pipeline to
build test and deploy enterprise
applications which means a tool that can
only build docker images isn't that
useful for creating real world
applications
luckily container boater isn't just a
docker builder by allowing you to run
multiple build steps each of which can
run any docker image as part of your
build well it provides a simple and
powerful way to customize build steps
and build environments you might be
wondering why is that useful well it
allows you to run unit tests with your
build or reduce the size of your final
image by remaking your image onto a
leaner smaller base image that removes
build artifacts test tool in and other
cred so to run this feature for yourself
here's what you need to know you can
customize build steps with a cloud build
Yambol file each build step runs in a
container you can bring your own
container images or use Google provided
ones your repository is mounted at slash
workspace in contents of slash workspace
are preserved from one build step to
another and this is exactly like Jenkins
build pipelines where you have artifacts
that are stashed or unstaffed from one
step of the pipeline to the next this
means that if you distribute your apps
as containers well you don't need to
host a Jenkins instance or a third-party
CI service to build and push images so
to illustrate this better let's use GCB
to build test and package an example go
application I want to remember that when
I submit the build to GC be my source
code is pulled into a workspace
directory from there GCB runs the
commands that I specify over the
contents of that workspace directory
it's also good to know that the
container builder team publishes and
maintains a set of docker containers
with common developer tools like git
docker the g-cloud command line
interface so I can use any of these to
run operations inside of my build now
using these tools I'm going to define a
cloud
Billiam Oh file this has a pipeline with
specific set of steps to run just like
in any build system but instead of
storing these images locally we use the
ones that are stored in the cloud first
go install will produce a binary that I
can use in my next step then we'll use
the go docker container image again to
test our code finally we'll use a docker
container to build an image this assumes
that there's a docker file in my
workspace if all of the above steps pass
then the final result of this will be GC
be example image when I submit the build
you can see all of these steps from the
cloud build Yama file run it so what's
the point
container builder is not just for
building docker containers but it's a
composable ecosystem that allows you to
use any build step for more information
about this be sure to check out the
links from ahmed and kelsey in the
description below and learn about more
advanced features of google container
builder like using build triggers to
automate creating containers be sure to
subscribe to the channel I'm Carter
Morgan and I'm telling you to tune in
next time to learn what's rolling out in
the next cloud rolling update thanks for
watching
check out previous episodes of cloud
rolling update and click here to watch
Kelsey's next talk on container builder
see you next time